unser zugeschaltet ist der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder schönen
guten tag
hallo grüß gott herr söder die korona
pandemie ist jetzt rund acht monate alt
aber noch immer gibt es keine
einheitlichen schutz und lernkonzepte
für die schulen warum ich glaube es wäre
sehr wichtig in der tat dass wir in
deutschland weit mehr einheitlichkeit
haben die kultusminister bemühen sich
darum aber ich glaube das wäre noch zu
vertiefen weil wenn wir die priorität
setzen und zwar national dass schule und
kita offen sind und weil es gute gründe
dafür gibt einerseits um die
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten die eltern
ihre sozusagen betreuung zu ermöglichen
aber auf der anderen seite den
schülerinnen und schüler auch
entsprechende bildung zu vermitteln wäre
mehr einheitlichkeit gut welche regeln
stellen sie sich davor als bayerischer
ministerpräsident was muss getan werden
denn das ist ja ein sehr vielen
bundesländern sehr unterschiedlich
ja in der tat richtig ich glaube wir
müssen einheitliche empfehlungen vom rk
ii haben die für alle anwendbar sind wir
in bayern haben momentan
infektionsgeschehen an der schule das
eigentlich noch relativ niedrig ist das
kann man so sagen
es handelt sich alles zum teil unter ein
prozent was die klassen betrifft bzw die
schulen die nicht erhoffen sind trotzdem
glaube ich zur vorsorge sollte man
folgendes machen erstens ich glaube dass
die masken pflicht an der schule sehr
sehr sinnvoll ist und zwar auch an der
grundschule die kinder kommen damit
hervorragend zurecht da gibt es kein
wirkliches problem
das ist die beste möglichkeit und wir
haben wissenschaftliche unterschiedliche
einschätzung derzeit ob kinder
vielleicht keine symptome aber doch
infektionsträger sinne der prävention
masken pflicht überall auch an der
grundschule
zweitens wir brauchen einheitliche
quarantäne regeln sowie des rk ist
derzeit vorschreibt denn ein hin und her
zum teil sogar ein bundesland
unterschiedlich für unsichere eltern
schüler und auch die lehrer es weder
unsere kollegin inga frenser schreibt
heute in einem bild kommentar sie selbst
mutter wer auch nur ein einziges mal
erlebt hat wie die jüngsten
pflichtbewusst maske tragen aber sich
dabei einfach nicht mehr auf das lernen
konzentrieren können würde niemals auf
die idee kommen sie spricht und
kritisiert die masten pflicht
insbesondere bei grundschulkindern an
das was wir von lehrerinnen und lehrern
und von schuldirektor
in bayern die das ja schon in der praxis
jetzt erlebt haben zeichnen dann etwas
anderes bild ich habe natürlich respekt
vor jeder meinung dazu
aber wir erleben eher umgekehrt dass die
schülerinnen schüler spielerisch war
damit umgehen als die eltern des
häufigsten finden oder auch wir
erwachsenen
es sind glaube ich wenn man am ende die
priorität setzen will schule offen zu
halten wenn man die priorität auch haben
will zu erreichen dass schule so lange
wie möglich auch präsenzunterricht
hatten die beiden schaltstellen dann
glaube ich ist eine möglichkeit entweder
abstand zu halten
das ist in einigen schulen räumlich
jederzeit möglich in vielen ist es aber
nicht möglich deswegen ist da wichtig
dass man die maske nimmt plus die luft
tagen zu schaffen es gibt nach wie vor
einzelne kommunen die sich schwer tun
trotz finanzielle angebote lüfter zu
machen auch das würde helfen beides im
zusammenspiel bringt eine entlastung
gerade für die kinder
was ist wenn dann tatsächlich etwas
passiert also an ist ein crooner fall
gibt sind dann 14 tage isolation für
schüler wirklich richtig er ist die
vorstellung ist es wäre völlig in
ordnung wenn des aks noch mal überprüft
auch mit den entsprechenden nationalen
referent stellt ob 14 tage notwendig
sind ob eine woche ausreichen würde
wie oft man dazwischen testen muss
bislang halten wir uns jedenfalls in
bayern relativ konsequent an die
vorgaben das rk an der stelle
das heißt die 14 tage auch mit der mit
der entsprechenden auflage der zwischen
zu testen
ich glaube wenn wir auch hier die
schnelltests kapazitäten stärker zum
einsatz bringen können
dann könnte es sein dass wir darauf
andere maßstäbe anlegen was die länge
der quarantäne betrifft aber dazu wäre
es natürlich notwendig dass das lka und
seine klare empfehlung gibt also da
lassen sie uns über einen thema sprechen
was viele menschen natürlich auch schon
jetzt bewegt weihnachten
gesundheitsministerien sparen hat
bereits angekündigt dass es da düster
aussehen könnte glauben sie dass wir uns
zumindest mit oma opa eltern onkel
unterm baum versammeln dürfen oder wird
es wie in italien wo es ja heute bereits
ein verbot gab dass man sich in der
großen familie trifft
schauen sie das hängt von den nächsten
zwei wochen ab im endeffekt haben wir
alles selbst in der hand
wenn es beurteilen müssen auch wie geht
es jetzt weiter wie es in die
perspektiven in den nächsten tagen und
dann wird sich zeigen was an weihnachten
tatsächlich stattfindet ich glaube aber
dass unser großes ziel nicht sein sollte
wohin kann man weihnachten in den urlaub
fahren sondern mit wem darf man zusammen
sein wie sie es angesprochen haben
und da sollte es uns gelingen das ist
das klare ziel das wir haben das so viel
familie wie möglich ist
möglich ist das weil es um sie zu können
jetzt gibt es bereits am montag eine
neue ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
natürlich bereits jetzt diskussionen
darüber gibt es dann verschärfung ist
das nicht viel zu früh um darüber zu
entscheiden
ja auf einen eindeutig um es endgültig
zu entscheiden aber es gibt ja schon die
ersten die über lockerungen reden wollen
wie ich heute haben wir einen weiteren
namen habe das kann es überhaupt nicht
sein
wir müssen nächste woche normal
bekräftigen glaube ich dass es jetzt
keine voreiligen lockerungen gibt und
wir müssen man darüber reden ob wir
nicht möglicherweise noch vor ablauf der
vier wochen auch uns dann nochmal
treffen und dann zu vereinbaren wie es
weitergehen wird
man muss ganz ehrlich sagen der
wendekreis von corona ist sehr sehr groß
durch die tatsache dass wir einen lock
darum jetzt leiht machen ist sich die
frage am ende zu stellen wie wird das
ganze und insofern glaube ich würde es
nicht die letzte mpk sein die wir haben
wir müssen das sehr eng beieinander
bleiben lieber öfters treffen und dann
entscheiden
als jetzt festzulegen er nächste woche
über für zwei drei wochen kennt wo sehen
sie denn überhaupt möglichkeiten der
verschärfung wenn die zahlen nicht
besser werden wissen sie ich rate uns im
moment dazu die frage ist mehr als
berechtigt da beratungs im moment dazu
das gilt auch für ferien
weihnachtsferien nicht jeden tag die
menschen heute foren sind wir uns mal
ein konzept das soll insgesamt für vier
wochen gelten wir sind jetzt sozusagen
in der zweiten woche und das gilt jetzt
einfach dass man uns umzusetzen
konsequent und dann zu schauen ob seine
wirkung zeigt und wenn ja welche wirkung
wie groß die ist wenn wir haben wir das
klare ziel am ende das wir nicht jede
woche jeden monaten eine lok da und
debatte bekommen müssen jetzt eine
nachhaltige entwicklung haben deswegen
sollten wir uns nicht jeden tag selbst
verunsichern
mit einem detail 4 am detail dort einer
kleinen einzelheiten
denn am ende braucht es ja eine
inhaltliche auch übereinstimmung und ich
glaube dass die mehrzahl der bürger die
maßnahmen für angemessen oder eher noch
zu wenig hält aber wir müssen noch an
die denken die skeptisch sind und denen
muss klar vermittelt werden nicht jeden
tag eine neue idee oder ein neues detail
sie sprechen diejenigen an die skeptisch
sind jetzt gab es in diesen tagen
mehrere studien zum ersten lockdown im
märz april und in diesen studien denen
kann man entnehmen dass ist eine menge
an opfern gab
und zwar deshalb weil sie nicht zum arzt
gegangen sind am ende aus angst
möglicherweise sich anzustecken also
tote durch den locker und hat die
politik der fehler gemacht im nachhinein
gibt es unterschiedliche studien es gibt
auch studien aus den usa die sie
erkennen die sagen dass bestimmte
ansteckungswege höher waren die
restaurants wie fitnessstudios und
anderes mehr als genau das worüber wir
jetzt sehr diskutiert haben ob das
notwendig ist
ich glaube zunächst einmal ist zu sagen
was wir im frühjahr sehr erfolgreich
waren dass die bekämpfung des log daten
betrifft er stellt sich jetzt einfach
die tatsache aus dass die todeszahlen
wieder sehr stark gewachsen sind was die
krankenhäuser voll laufen obwohl wir die
kapazitäten deutlich erhöht haben oder
völlig vergessen jetzige belastung der
krankenhäuser ist ja eine im grunde
genommen schwierigere im frühjahr das
sich nur nicht so abzeichnet weil die
besser vorbereitet sind durch mehr
betten besser vorbereitet sind durch
auch therapeutische behandlungen bei den
ersten anzeichen in den krankenhäusern
sind das heißt im grunde genommen
profitieren wir momentan von unserem
guten gesundheitssystem im vergleich zu
allen anderen ländern
ich glaube dass die frage wer waren zum
arzt geht ja nicht ein verbot war
beispielsweise das war eine
psychologische wirkung von vielen
menschen in einen andern fall
und darum ist es immer auch gerade im
moment wichtig durch die gesteigerten
kapazitäten in den krankenhäusern und
auch durch die hohe sensibilität dass
wir da keine verunsicherung der
bevölkerung zusätzlich bekommen die dann
möglicherweise zu solchen zurückhaltung
und führt was den arzt besuchen sie
sprechen die krankenhäuser an sagen dass
diese langsam verlaufen wie dramatisch
ist die lage auf den intensivstationen
momentan und wie viele tage woche haben
wir noch das ist wirklich dramatisch
wird ja das hängt jetzt
in der tat von den weiteren verlauf ab
die kurve flacht etwas ab aber nicht
wirklich was ein hoffnungsvolles signal
wäre gleichzeitig steigt die zahl der
toten gab viele die gesagt haben nahe
todesfälle wird es kaum geben
fakt ist aber dass mit einer bestimmten
anzahl an infektionen auch das
hineinwachsen wieder die alten und
pflegeheime stattfindet in die
krankenhäuser über also auch in die
risikogruppen und das damit auf einem
mit einem satz quasi die zahl der
todesfälle ansteigt wenn sie vor die
zeitung sieht ali und anderswo sehr
besorgniserregend dort waren ja auch
viel härtere massnahmen getroffen
wir haben den mildesten quasi auf dem
kontinent ihr bei uns in europa auf noch
sehr dass es trotzdem wirkt also die
zahlen sind regeln als schon sehr sehr
voll nicht überall
regional sind sie zum teil sehr sehr
voll und vor allem haben wir auch das
problem wir haben natürlich mehr betten
in deutschland zum glück in sechs
monaten war es ja kaum möglich das
national mehr pflegekräfte ausgebildet
wurden da entstehen dann schon engpässe
wenn nicht bei den betten aber doch bei
der betreuung letzte frage an sie ja so
der professor schmidt chanasit hat
dieser tage gesagt das ist
möglicherweise nicht der letzte winter
mit einschränkung ist und er hat gesagt
es kann sein dass wir 22 22 oder sogar
bis 2023 mit krone leben müssen kann das
tatsächlich sein
also ich glaube dass coroner nicht
einfach verschwinden wird und auch 23 24
nicht aber wie wir damit leben
das wird anders sein denn ich bin sehr
optimistisch dass wenn der impfstoff
zugelassen wird wenn ein impfstoff in
deutschland zugelassen wird
dann dürfte er auch sicher sein wir
haben damit die strengste antworten dass
allein mit der tatsache eine zulassung
des impfstoffs von einer dauernden
durchimpfung der bevölkerung wenn die
menschen ist wollen und mitmachen
ja wenn er keine impfpflicht auf keinen
fall machen aber dass wir dann die
risikogruppen reduzieren können die
sterblichkeit reduzieren können
das ist uns dann auch gelingen kann
einen anderen umgang mit corona zusammen
ich bin keiner ifa optimist wieder ein
oder andere der gesagt hat es gibt keine
zweite welle
aber ich bin ein mensch mit realistische
hoffnung und die hoffnung gründet sich
sowie die sorge auf wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen und die werden mit einem
impfstoff verbunden nachdem jetzt klar
ist dass im stoff gesichert ist
wir bereiten impfzentren überall vor die
lagerkapazitäten wenn das dann klappt
und das go gegeben wird dann glaube ich
könnte man impfen ich würde mich selber
übrigens auch impfen lassen wenn es
zulässig ist herzlichen dank herr so da
und alles gute nach münchen ihnen auch
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren